ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi a
domenica e quindi stiamo su aprilia ogni
volta che faccio io devo fare una
premessa perchè se no non va bene devo
perdere tempo
allora facciamo questa volta dato che
non ne ho uno stop di 3 secondi e poi
partiamo ok perfetto grande ragazzi un
miracolo che sia la seconda volta che
faccio un episodio di attivisti filo
ormai è un evento earth adventure
facciamo il primo il primo guerra è
finito mio figlio non si posso credere
grande così dai ragazzi come primo
livello era potevo scegliere bene 1
miglio a giampà residui della febbre
maledizione ma era che a questo sì con
questo ci sia la facciamo finta e quello
di prima non c'era grandi album vice
thing ma le donne culo ma che cazzo fai
questa roba da guardare lepre
assolutamente lista roba ma che cazzo
successo per prendi prendi la fiom che
ha fatto alla prima mi sono infilato un
arpione nel culo poi ho preso dal sacro
si sa come va bene epic sword traumi mi
mancavano gli sport trovo ragazzini
manca ace babbo natale by zio che tra
poco ti tocca lavorare che natale
ragazzi non ce l'ho con babbo natale ma
ce l'ho con quei giudizi che si che cosa
è successo
[Musica]
ma i ragazzi non cipiglio più nel
risvolto abbiate pazienza ma porca [ __ ]
cioè nel colo cosa fate sport cattolici
sono dei bambini le spade le spade mi
servivano nonché per infilarsi nel
deretano che ha finalmente cazzo è stata
dura ma ce l'ho fatta ho pagato una
testa jazz the claw in hard ed
aggiungono anche la scritta difficile
perché pensano che non ci riesca ad
occhi chiusi non edizione
ormai ho vinto perché la sparate tutte
trendy si no ma porca [ __ ] baia di
risaltare davis o saltano chi cazzo qua
ma che caso non ci posso credere di non
puoi farmi questo è di non abbiamo vinto
ma devi solo saltare
no ragazzi non ci voglio credere ed i
ragazzi non ce la farò mai a presto di è
impossibile o no non ci posso si si si
prendi quel cazzo di manubrio non ha
[ __ ] mente senso
un le culle ma porca [ __ ] sì ci ho
messo mezz'ora ma ne è valsa la pena
maledizione tra l'altro come cazzo sono
morto non si capisce ma non importa
ce l'abbiamo fatta io vado a dormire
contento adesso maledizione c'è sono sub
sono su velociraptor perché sono su un
velociraptor qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegarmelo
perché non lo sa che così sexy oggi li
ho non trovo lì prendere un complimento
zio ce la fai quello che vuoi comunque
va beh
[Musica]
red boltro ragazzi da secoli che non
faceva ball trovo incredibile che se ne
sia uscito un altro ho già vinto malizia
ma porca tra ragazzi ma quanto ecco
perché non facciamo più volte rho mi ero
dimenticato perché ero troppo bravo
cazzo sono troppo un fenomeno a ste cose
vico subito praticamente guardate
io devo smetterla di fare i livelli
perché poi mi prendo troppo bene
l'ultima volta devo riuscire a cat in
the box da tempo che non facevo death in
the box mi mancavano c'è anche un tizio
che mi piglia se arrivo aspettate un
attimo che devo arrivarci miei figli
però è assicurami che mi bimbi perché
sennò tp a schiaffi alla stessa che ce
la faccio la faccio mai così sei un
pezzente di merda su lido pezzente di
merda vieni giù ma che cosa è successo
[Musica]
no non ho capito che cazzo è successo ma
non voglio far domande va bene così
siamo tutti contenti ok 99,99999 9999
qualcosa per cento in fossimo ragazzi
già posso fare non pensa velocemente ma
io non penso
ragazzi io non so pensava che cazzo
fermi [ __ ] card debt può simon
cioè difficile ma possibile per babbo
natale tutto è possibile
che cazzo sta facendo o di rock il di
old men che cazz avete controllo ciak
devo prenderla ma no
[Musica]
queste
younes spyphone secoli ragazzi che non
faceva uno spike che cazzo fanno chieco
d'oro ma poi con tutti quelli che
c'erano proprio luca il padre
maledizione coloro che non sono per un
cazzo
va bene un paio
bottled machine che macchina voglio una
coca e grazie una sola ho detto una
porca [ __ ] non è difficile e adesso
maledizione togliti lurida ma porchia
drives ragazzi non se lo faccio a
prenderla maledizione perché c'è sta
merda che mi copre comunque distributore
in e chris foy me lo spiegate che cazzo
dovrebbe servire non lo so bevi rock
swing
andiamo con baby ma i bambini non
dovrebbero fare queste cose sono brutte
ama infatti le spine sono finte i
ragazzi di spine la fate finta perché un
livello per bambini mi sembra giusto a
vinci vibo stupido che alla fine ci sono
le caramelle e forse qualcuno ti
cambierà anche il pannolino credo non
sarò io a farlo ovviamente si si lo fi
che le staccionate c'è un'altra ce n'è
una il braccio staccati per poi vedere
che sei un banda non ci posso credere
sì sì ho vinto ho vinto non mi ha dato
la vittoria ma ho vinto non me ne fotte
niente non riuscivo a vincere perché
c'era il braccio che vi rimaneva
attaccato in un modo osceno
ma ho vinto quindi va benissimo ospite
guida fino all'ospedale vai così non vi
assicuro niente con steve in ambulanza e
ve lo dico e sono peggio di quelle di
gta investono il mondo ragazzata una
limousine come cazzo può essere così
piccola spiegatemelo cos'è sta roba qua
io noi schiacciava otto ragazzi se con
la stessa cosa cazzo sta facendo quei
due porci dietro voi dovete essere
scortati in ospedale non dovete fare i
porci diviene bora che schifo
nel senso va veramente sono io autista
che ho bisogno dell'ambulanza non voi
che state dietro comunque andiamo avanti
lo stesso ragazzi sto livello non ha un
senso sono pro intanto chi dietro si
stanno ripassando tutto il kamasutra non
fa niente ma non i pub high skill stampo
razzista portando due tizi salvo mai nel
frattempo ne sta investendo altri 350
quindi non ho capito il senso ma va bene
così poi grazie perfetto ragazzi di
torje lauti perché la tizia piange
cos'è non sei bravo allen e anche a fare
sesso padre di yuki cosa cazzo sai fare
niente purtroppo o perfetto trovato
questo boltro che per i prof
c'era scritto pro è quindi esigo un
qualcosa di difficile
[ __ ] va bè ragazzi voglio vedere che
cazzo ne avete inviato come livelli in
postivo per fa vj mi serviva affetto
perché cos'è sta roba fa bacula
no ragazzi sto facendo non ci posso ma
porca [ __ ]
no ragazzi non ci voglio veramente
credere che sono morto ma porca [ __ ]
dal annunci sì sì ce la posso fare
allora non è così ma che cazzo allora
ragazzi io non ci credo che non riesce a
fare
ostinelli stronzate stronzate eliminate
l'ultima frase che ho detto perché una
puttanata ci riesca come spike fall per
farvi j anche questo mi mancava
tantissimo lo faccio con enti fa di
questo è il mio primo spyphone quindi
forza ed i su forza e disse sì
che cazzo cos'è mista attacca mi stanno
attaccando del jet va bene così beh
ragazzi di concludere qui l'episodio
spero la prossima settimana di domenica
di farlo di riuscire a farcela fare è
più miss normalmente no perché succede
sempre qualcosa che non riesco a farlo
ma stavolta ci prova in tutti i modi ve
lo giuro comunque ragazzi dei video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come non i video trovate nella
descrizione se se ne per i siti scrivete
venirci vediamo il prossimo vito bei
ragazzi